who do you think's easier to please men
or women men are very easy to men for
sure men so men men men are easy to
please you but by what you're saying
their women are doing all these things
to to win the attention and the
affection of men but men are easier to
please who's more who's more inclined to
do self-improvement to attract the
opposite sex women
they go for plastic surgery absolutely
rubbish I think it's women it was more
than men when we talk when is when is
anywhere when have you ever heard the
man on the internet say I want a woman
that made six figures when have you ever
heard that
doesn't exist
and if a guy was to say he wants a woman
that makes lots of uh not that uh men
want women that are broke but you're not
going to hear a man come out and say I
want a woman a woman that's a
millionaire it doesn't exist